when it comes to cost optimization you
want to make sure that you're running
your workloads as efficiently as
possible
of course that definitely means not
paying for resources that you're not
using
today we'll talk about google kubernetes
engine's auto scaling
and go over some tips let's go beyond
your gke bill
[Music]
one major advantage of kubernetes is how
it was built with scaling in mind
and gke adds even more options to scale
it can work pretty well without much
configuration but there's a lot of cost
optimization potential
by going deeper in the last video we
talked a lot about how to choose the
right machine type
as always it really depends on knowing
your application's resource needs
and that's just as important for
configuring audit scaling
i'll start with an introduction to auto
scaling and then dive deep into
horizontal
and vertical auto scaling for your
workloads starting with the basics auto
scaling
is really all about two things getting
additional resources when demand
increases
and shutting down or removing resources
when demand decreases
by setting auto scaling up efficiently
and specific to your workload
you'll be able to minimize wasted cost
in order to understand how you should
configure auto scaling
let's simplify everything into workloads
and infrastructure
workloads are made up of pods which are
running containerized applications
infrastructure is made up of nodes which
are responsible for the actual resources
like
computing capacity and memory for each
of these there's also two ways to scale
horizontally or vertically horizontal
scaling is done by adding more pods or
nodes
if there's a lot of demand coming in the
auto scaler can try to increase the
number of pods or nodes to handle it
vertical scaling is done by making pods
or nodes bigger
when demand increases a larger pod or
node may be able to reduce the burden by
handling more
with those basics let's talk about how
gke handles auto scaling
let's start with the workload and pod
size by looking at the aptly named
horizontal pod auto scaler and vertical
pod auto scaler
for horizontal scaling you'll need a
metric that represents the demand on
your workload
such as cpu utilization or requests per
second
with that target the horizontal pod auto
scaler can try to add pods to get your
workload
back to your desired state adding pods
should mean that the work is spread out
evenly
and a metric like average cpu
utilization would go
down across your pods similarly if
there's not much demand the autoscaler
can remove pods which is great for
saving on costs
when using a horizontal pod auto scaler
remember that there might be a lag time
depending on how long it takes your
container to start up
setting the correct amount of available
metric space or buffer
requires knowing how well you can handle
spikes in demand
if the buffer is too small and the pods
take a long time to spin up
your app might get overloaded on the
other hand too large of a buffer can
lead to wasted resources
and extra costs so a few things to keep
in mind
understand what capacity might be needed
for a spike and set your buffer
accordingly
do what you can to have your pods spin
up quickly and shut down efficiently
make sure to set up the right readiness
and live probes so gke can make the best
decisions
and remember to make sure that your
metric server is always up and running
i know we haven't talked about what some
of these mean but keep that in mind and
we'll come back to these when we dive
deeper into optimizing your applications
so that's horizontal pod auto scaling
now let's look at vertical
pod auto scaling rather than adding
additional pod replicas
here the pods actually get recreated
with more or less resources depending on
cpu and memory usage
remember that too few resources can
overload your apps and too many
resources
will mean that you're paying for things
that you're not using vertical pod auto
scaling works to solve this and has
three modes off initial and auto
when it's off no auto scaling actually
happens but the auto scaler is looking
at your pods
and creating recommendations based on
usage that you can inspect
which also happens in the other two
modes if it's set to initial
those recommendations will be used to
create resized pods as they're needed
after creating a pod at the recommended
size based on those recommendations
it won't change the pod size afterward
if the auto scaler is set to auto those
recommendations will be used to
regularly resize pods
by deleting them and recreating them
with the adjusted amounts
in general you should make sure that
vertical pod auto scaling is off for at
least a day
or ideally a week in order to collect
recommendation data
then you can switch to initial or auto
based on your needs
or you can just keep it off and review
the recommendations to manually adjust
your pods
here are some things to keep in mind if
you're looking to handle sudden spikes
use horizontal pod auto scaling instead
vertical pod auto scaling can take a bit
longer than horizontal
since it can grow the number of pods
without taking any offline
make sure that your app can actually
benefit from additional resources
if it's single threaded or limited by
workers rather than resources
vertical pod auto scaling might not help
at all set minimums
and maximums and avoid any large changes
since abrupt changes can require new
deployments
don't forget to keep your metric server
healthy node
auto provisioning which we'll talk more
about in the next video can help by
creating new nodes that can better fit
your resize pods
and if you're using auto make sure that
your workload can handle restarts
also you'll want to choose a pod
disruption budget to control the number
of changes
happening at once you can use both
horizontal and vertical pod autoscaling
at the same time
but there's a few things that you need
to be careful about first of all you
shouldn't use them on the same resource
like cpu or memory both auto scalers are
trying to react to changes in demand
on that same metrics and that could
cause overlapping problems
but you can always keep vertical pod
autoscaler in off mode
to get recommendations without any
changes actually being made
along with using horizontal pod auto
scaling so your app can scale
horizontally based on cpu utilization
while you can make decisions based on
those vertical pod auto scaler
recommendations
or you can use a custom metric for the
horizontal auto scaler like requests per
second
in addition you should ensure that your
deployments are receiving enough traffic
when both auto scalers are enabled that
way the vertical pod
auto scaler can get accurate data for
creating recommendations
as always it depends on your workload to
know whether you should use horizontal
vertical or both pod auto scalers but
we're not stopping there
on the next video we'll cover the
cluster auto scaler and
node auto provisioning remember to check
out the link in the description for the
full guide on gke cost optimization